how good was my introduction or Tillery
angle is just another way of rephrasing
questions that we're not sure how to
deal with in other ways so that they
look like questions you already know how
to solve and then you can do it okay so
in order to get at this question I want
to consider this graph the one where we
looked at just now under revision except
I just want to think about what it looks
like okay now let's draw this just
roughly let's just sketch it out usually
we draw things from north of 2pi but
today to illustrate something unusual I
want to go double that domain not to 4pi
okay so let's sketch it out roughly at
the beginning of the year and a further
graphs and locusts we looked at what
happens when you graph things that are
made up of two other things right so we
use addition of coordinates right now
that's not always the best method but he
are because these graphs up here on if
they repeat this is kind of a good way
to go so draw in roughly maybe if you
have some other colors that might help
draw in y equals sine X and draw y
equals cos x okay and don't forget we're
going not to 4pi so it's two lots of
both
all right now it doesn't need to be
beautiful
it just needs to be close enough so that
we can notice a pattern so in blue I've
got some cause and in red so I think
back to edition of ordinance how do we
usually go about this you think about
the easy to work out parts first and
then you just sort of fill in the dots
based on the parts that are easy to
determine so for instance up here at the
beginning okay
signs equal to zero and cons equal to 1
0 plus 1 is what in the same way here at
playa - right cause is equal to 0 and
sine is equal to 1 so that's also gonna
be 1
they in between it looks to me like
you've got these values that are both
gonna add up to something above 1 so
it's probably going to head up a little
higher
how high not entirely sure but a little
bit higher now somewhere in between here
and here there's a point where the Reds
positive and the Blues negative that
should be equal right so when you add
them together they're gonna cancel each
other out
you should get zero somewhere and you've
probably noticed the same thing
happening over here 0 minus 1 is gonna
give me minus 1 another 0 and minus 1
gives you minus 1 and in between you're
just like this went the bar of a little
bit has been request you're going to get
sort of the reverse happening over here
and by this time you're probably
starting to see a bit of a pattern okay
let me try and ya know and we'll see why
well okay what will sorry here ok so
doubles double that so in terms of scale
on a bit off okay but it won't go all
the way up to yeah okay
all right so let's try and connect the
dots let's see what's going on this is
going to come up head back up now by the
list of things again I'm gonna go
through some way through here
okay okay so it's not pretty but it's
enough for us to notice something namely
that when you take sine and cosine right
and you add them together sine and
cosine Oh what we call wave functions
the cold wave functions because the
shape of it looks like a light wave
sound wave water wave they all behave in
the same kind of way when you add
together these two wave functions sine
cosine blue and red what you end up
getting is well another wave function
but it's different how is it different
it's bigger okay so a more technical way
of saying that is that the amplitude is
greater the case the amplitudes changed
but not only who is the amplitude
changed sign right it starts off as zero
right so it starts off right at the
center and cosine starts off at one so
it starts off at those extremities as
far as it can go but now a new one it
doesn't quite start at the center or at
the ends right kind of starts in the
middle right so what does that mean not
only the amplitude changed but also it's
been phase shifted okay how much has it
been phase shifted not entirely sure but
it's different in amplitude and phase
that's the important thing
okay now we we just said just now we're
like well it's kind of different but we
don't know how different so I wonder
based on what we already know what we've
got this year for instance okay how
could you yeah what kind of like what
precisely what graph isn't what's
actually equal to hmm what was different
in amplitude okay what number determines
the amplitude of a wave function it's
gonna it's gonna be the coefficient
right yeah this this number out the
front in this case is spoken everyone
okay that's why the amplitude of blue
and red are oh wow okay what about the
phase what determines the face what
number do I ask to adjust yeah I have to
I have to sort of wanna find this right
maybe like X plus 90 what's minus 9y
whatever
okay so that'll move it back and forth
so therefore here's what I'm gonna
suggest I think that sine X plus cos X
is equivalent to hmm now I could pick
either but just for the sake of
simplicity for now I'm gonna pick a sine
function that's different in amplitude
so that coefficient at the front like
you told me is different and it's also
different its phase so it's been sort of
nudged a bit to the left or to the right
okay now my question is what would these
two numbers be okay now they're twists
to work this out the first way is to
draw back on almost recently been
spending a lot of time in calculus right
how could you use calculus
differentiation stationary points so
work out the amplitude and the phase of
this thing yeah
good good so if I can work out where
this stationary point is okay number one
the y-coordinate what to tell me the
amplitude number two the x-coordinate
what to tell me something about its
phase shift so let's work this out okay
if that's why do you want the X is equal
to okay nice simple functions what do we
get
what's the derivative sign turns into
cos turns into okay now remember well it
was a stationary point don't forget
there's an infinite number of stationary
points okay so I just want the first one
that'll do
that's enough to work out these two bits
okay so I want to let it equal 0 okay so
let's go ahead and solve this cos x
minus sine X 0 so sine is equal to equal
to 1 what's the first enter it's in that
equation 45 degrees or PI over 4 okay
now we're going to encourage you to try
to start thinking more and more in
radians as you can mainly because you're
pretty good at degrees so okay all right
so let's think about this x equals PI
over 4 hmm if I want to work out this
amplitude I need to know how high I am
right so how do I do that I'm going to
take this and pop it into my Y equation
right so at x equals plan for right
what's y equals two sine PI + 4 which is
exactly 1 over root 2 okay and cost my 4
which is the same okay so put your fat
fractures together divide through that's
my Y value
okay sir what's that saying this point
okie is pining for root two okay so
let's you suggest at the at least right
this art is amplitude that's 1.4
whatever whatever okay
root to sign now this phase is a little
bit trickier but think about it this way
I always thinking in terms of sign right
we just think of that normal sign this
saw this red curve here right where does
it usually have a stationary point
usually it usually has a stationary
point at 90 degrees at PI on to okay but
this is telling me it's not a prior to
anymore it's at PI on four was it prior
to now it's moved over to the left pound
form okay I've been moved from 90 to 45
so 45 degrees through the left right or
pilot four radians to the left how do
you shift something to the left yeah
that's confusing isn't it right if you
remember you know say graph like that to
move it over to the left do you say y
equals x plus one all squared and then
your roots at minus one which is still
left okay so following with this graph
to the left palm for radians